it only comes down to how much value you
are providing on average to the
customers that are coming to you and
then taking a percentage of that value
well I'll tell you what not to do look
at the rest of the market and take the
average and then go a little bit lower
which is what most people do it has
nothing to do with how much it costs you
to deliver it how much time how much
effort any of that it's literally just
what is my average outcome over what
period of time and then how can I take a
percentage of that outcome on average
that I deliver to customers I'm a big
believer in 10 to 20 percent of the
value that you generate for the average
customer